vendredi midi à Montreuil banlieue de
l'Est de Paris leur état évalué et
réparer les dégâts de la nuit
didier est venu prêter main forte à sa
belle-fille propriétaire de ce commerce
c'est désolant parce que ils ont cassé
ils ont volé ils ont détruit ça nous
fait mettre 10 personnes au chômage
technique au moins dans le quartier il
est dommages attirent des curieux des
échanges et parfois place à des tensions
mais surtout a de la consternation ces
derniers jours en plus des commerces des
voitures et des édifices publics ont été
brûlés ou endommagés je pense que la
communauté quoi que la communauté puisse
faire
à quelque part pour une simple raison
c'est qu'on va détruire il va falloir un
jour le remplacer les scènes auxquels on
assiste à Montreuil sont loin d'être
unique selon les autorités la nuit
dernière 500 bâtiments ont été
endommagés à l'échelle de la France 2000
véhicules ont été incendies
à Aubervilliers au nord-est de Paris il
ne reste que les carcasses de ses 12
autobus qui était à l'arrêt dans le
dépôt les bus qui ont brûlé derrière
nous je le dis vraiment avec force il
servent tous les jours aux habitants des
banlieues au quartier populaire ce soir
le ministère de l'Intérieur a demandé
que tous les autobus et tous les
tramways du pays cessent de circuler à
partir de 21 heures
pour éviter les émeutes et les violences
des derniers jours le gouvernement
promet encore plus d'effectif notamment
des véhicules blindés de la gendarmerie
mais les 40 000 policiers et gendarmes
déployés dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi n'ont pas permis d'apaiser les
tensions en une nuit plus de 800
personnes ont été interpellées le tiers
sont des mineurs selon les autorités
c'est la responsabilité des parents de
les garder au domicile et donc il est
important pour l'inquiétude de tous que
la responsabilité parentale puisse
pleinement s'exercer
vendredi des tensions éclatées dès
l'après-midi des boutiques ont notamment
été pillées à Strasbourg et à Marseille
[Applaudissements]
à Montreuil dès la mi-journée on se
préparait pour une autre soirée
débordement selon Yasmine résidant des
banlieues pour obtenir un réel
apaisement le gouvernement devra
sérieusement se pencher sur les
pratiques policières qui ont mené à la
mort du jeune Naël
sur un gosse de 17 ans la maman refuse
d'obtempérer ces trois ans de prison et
une amende c'est pas un assassinat en
fait mais à son avis ce n'est pas en
détruisant ces quartiers que ce message
sera entendu ici rafale Bouvier au clair
Radio-Canada à Montreuil